[Music]
in Hollywood's golden age musicals of
America out dancing and two of the
greatest partners anyone could hope for
were an American in Paris and a
scarecrow in Oz present the Award for
Best Original Score here they are again
Gene Kelly and ray Bolger
[Music]
[Music]
before we turn to the Music Awards there
is something I'd like to do if you're
gonna ask me to dance forget it
well if you don't ask me I won't ask you
they got a deal I'd like to reintroduce
the president of the Academy mr. gene
Allen
many of you know
Kelly's house was vetted by a fire last
Christmas among the very one of the
valuable losses was the Oscar the
Academy had given him back in 1951 for
his magnificent and brilliant
contribution to the art of choreography
on film Jean the officers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we often force in the Board of Governors
once an acceptable to the replacement
and Filter
I do Thank You Jean and
this is just the nicest thing now I must
tell you I I can't I'm not completely
surprised because I was tipped off and I
knew they're gonna do it I guess they
thought I'd cry or something and I'm
about to so you're all so nice thank you
that's all
back to work back to work for best
achievement for best achievement in
Original Score the nominees are
Leonard Rosenman for Cross Creek John
Williams for the Return of the Jedi bill
conti for the right stuff
Michael Gove for the terms of endearment
[Music]
jerry goldsmith for under fire and the
winner is bill Conti for the right stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
every one that I should thank my mother
my father my wife my daughters Nicole
and Raquel oh that knew that this was
going to happen I don't know how Bob
Chatt off Irwin Winkler believed in me
from the beginning Alberta and Melinda
Nathan Capra Angela Molly to Cassidy all
the musicians that played and the
engineer that recorded it
Danny Wallen thank you all thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
he what a nice gesture for the Academy
to replace jeans Oscar he lost in his
home if they are that they're still in a
generous mood perhaps the Academy would
like to replace some items I lost in my
home this past year
they can start with a knife and a fork
to present the nominees and the Oscar
for Best Original Song score or
adaptation score is a gentleman whose
long and distinguished career has set
high standards both as a performer and a
composer mr. Neil Diamond
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much you know they never
really was such a thing as a completely
silent movie films were always meant to
be experienced with an accompanying
music score played by a piano or an
orchestra in theatre or nowadays
recorded with state-of-the-art equipment
as an integral part of the motion
picture now with the help of our musical
director for this evening mr. Ian Frazer
the artist nominated this year in the
category of original song score or
adaptations for show the power of music
combined with film and those nominees
are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for adaptation score of the sting to
Lalo Schifrin
[Music]
[Music]
for adaptation scorp trading places over
Bernstein
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and for regional song score Kendall
Michelle Legrand and Allen and Marilyn
Bergman
[Music]
and the winner is gentle Michelle
LeGrande Allen and Marilyn Bergman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much I'm very
grateful for this I'm very grateful to
for the privilege of the experience of
having worked on Yentl which was a which
is a story of a woman with a dream
a woman with a struggle and life has a
way of imitating art in very interesting
ways we worked in an atmosphere of
creativity of collaboration of
excitement energy synergy that allowed
us to do our best work I think and for
that I thank Barbara Streisand
[Applause]
[Music]
very good
but most of all Walker wherever you are
[Applause]
and I it is a marvelous experience
working with a woman as I have all my
creative life and Barbara just made it
that much better
she's just terrific and so is this
composure over here it's just I have to
tell you experience of the four of us
really loved each other a great deal and
we loved the project and when you do
something in love with PPO of something
really nice happens thank you all very
much just want to tell you that it was
such a pleasure for me to work with
Marilyn to work with Barbara to work
with people around us we spend years of
love and I'm ready to do it again any
time thank you very much
[Applause]
all of those three people have given us
so much wonderful music Michelle the
Grande and Alan and Marilyn Bergman but
as brilliant as they are not every song
that they write of course is a hit some
of you may remember in earlier song some
years ago by Alan and Marilyn that
didn't do as well as it should
was called welcome home Amelia Earhart